oh mein gott ich habe noch richtig lag
um ein gott war das episch das waren
richtig epigenetischer hallo ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren compassion ein nicht
um komfort sondern heute mal zusammen
mit neuer minecraft dabei simon wieder
antennen ist ich verstehe nicht was den
schlafrhythmus hat das ist unglaublich
wir werden jetzt einfach eine kleine
folge aufnehmen der wir ganz kurz
erzählen wollten wenn ihr scheint
einfach direkt die sonne ins gesicht
besuch mal so zu bleiben ja genau
wir wollen einfach nur kurz sagen dass
white nm also youtube snacks minecraft
das turnier fängt ab heute an ihr könnt
einfach oben in den link in der
beschreibung klicken da gelangt ihr
direkt auf den kanal y tm also bei
youtube sechsmal größer und da haben wir
ein video hochgeladen was zu circa acht
minuten lautet wenn wir alles erklären
wenn ihr teilnehmen wollt welche preise
gewinnen können was das ganze turnier
bringt und so weiter also da einfach
draufklicken dann könnten damit machen
und deswegen habe ich gedacht damit wir
das nicht einfach so blöd mit dem
schwarzen weg wie machen spielen wir
doch hier einfach nur runde
ja ich werde für snow oder welche nicht
nur folgen etwa für gut ich hätte gerne
noch geschossen
nur eine eine blöde panzer welches team
wir haben vergessen passant zu lösen
du hast christ die ministranten passt
ein pass nahm erst mit dem anderen in
einem team
dann müsste auch akzeptieren dass mit
dem ein team kann ich küsse dich keiner
richtig und das ist ganz schön rum ich
bin auf einmal wieder eine kirche gut
mein wort für alle die es noch nicht
kennen ihr kennt einfach so fest ihr
kennt es gibt halt
mehrere teams 43 panisch lang genau 3
also es gibt diamant lapis und gold und
es geht jetzt 18 stunden auch viel glück
und 18 sekunden dann geht's los
hier sind die leute die mit mir im team
sind und wir müssen an die anderen teams
ausschalten die erste mit wie viel leben
24 24 genau richtig richtig kombiniert
der showblock so jetzt geht für mich los
und jetzt muss mir anderen töten
der folgenschwere hab keins diese map
nenne ich finde ich einfach nie sachen
du musst dir in die häuser gucken gleich
am anfang was bekommen ich strenge mich
auch immer schon den stoff die ganzen
krieg war ja so weiter
na klar ich war letztens gut so
und schlawiner jamann
ich habe jemanden getötet ich habe 10
uhr ab räumt insgesamt fast 200 190
kannst ja noch einholen kann ja auf
jeden fall
das ist ja auch sehr loyal
da gibt's einige spezialisten die denken
wir stecken das anscheinend richtig
nicht ganz so schlimm man da sind fünf
leute denke doch nicht raus
das cool ich habe vor dessen die shops
king of pop shop in shops ist aneinander
farbe steht du hast nun einen job ich
habe jetzt zwei prepaid verbrauch ich
aber erstmal bogen mehr an bogen und
pfeile
hier liegt ein stein schwert bogen ich
brauche bogen lichtbogen leute bogen
morgen trends auf den teamchef schreiben
naja das team
ich war total aufgeregt verstecken hier
um nach uns lehrern dabei einen bogen
bekommen also weit wollen ganz gut sagen
worum es da geht das ist ein hammer ja
okay ist sein konntest wo ihr wenn ihr
wenn ihr irgendwas minecraft könnt könnt
ihr uns ein video schicken muss die oft
nicht gelistet hochladen aber wird noch
mal alles auf dem kanal erklärt und da
könnt ihr euer minecraft quartal zeigen
was ihr talent ihre zahlen in minecraft
aber wenn ihr jetzt besitzt und auch
nicht aber wenn er eins ab wenn ihr
denkt der aa ich kann gut zu dem asics
erstellen
dann seid ihr da direkt richtig weil
dann könnt ihr dort mitmachen und
eventuell fette preise absahnen
die preis war
auf dem kanal gezeigt als am besten
einfach auf den kanal gehen und sich da
das video am gucken und seite schon auf
der richtigen seite ach das ist ein
typisch ist auch auf dich und ich kann
ihn schlagen sagt er vielleicht raum an
die doch jetzt geht ja einige will muss
hier
wenn die reinigen
internetgeschwindigkeiten haben dann
kannst du nicht schlagen
aber ben spies und wohnung gerade da
sehe ich den kleinen crafter 151
verloren wollte ich jetzt wirklich nicht
ich lauf weg vor denen ich hoffe nicht
ich hoffe mein gott sachen ich kann
schon wieder nicht schlagen doch jetzt
geht ist der selbst selbst mein gott
hatte richtig viel hätte richtig viele
feierlichkeiten bis sechs pfeile dadurch
dass man bekämpft
schlappe mein gott ich habe ich noch
richtig lang um ein gott war das episch
das war ein richtig epigenetischer
schluss den paketversand druck einfach
so über die komplette entfernen ein
ansprechen konnte kräfte mit der pvp pro
geschlecht ist doch gar nicht im sommer
dass ich so eine gift bombe geben wird
dann finden wir auf den gegner schießt
dann fliegt er ganz so hoch und der das
ganze gesicht verschwommen von dem
gegner
nein ich hab mich getroffen dafür
treffen noch eine runde auf dann haben
wir wenigstens tsuruga zehn minuten
zweistellig
wenn ihr also ich bin einfach immer
weiter auf ihr direkt auf 101 ich
versuche gerade setzt obstsalat mit 40
joghurt und müsli drin und kugel christ
und so gegessen
keine gute kombination auf der lab mit
cookie christa hamann keine gute
kombination anmelden anmelden anmelden
anmelden melden melden anmelden catcher
berliner kicker werde die goldene
zutaten aber läuft gut hier meinen
und nicht gleich und drauf macht ja auch
nicht gewinnen
na ja unsere neuen server seien relativ
teuer kann daher nur ein verlust machen
also die machen das alles nur für die
community damit ihre oft wählen können
ich hab den pass geschickt zusammen muss
ich keine lösung die allerdings immer
noch akzeptieren
das akzeptiere ich passe einfach fast
einsamer tod akzeptiert normal
akzeptiert nicht online pass ja hier ist
ein einsamer tod zusammen spielen
zusammen
da ist die tante die kennst du schon gar
nicht an wen können sich lieber diese
pflanzlich um abend jetzt
schon mal gespielt nur noch nie es ist
die falsche richtung da ist nur ein paar
kisten
ich hab noch gar nichts muss einfach
gucken wohin zum ausländer raus wenn das
hier so eine große halle und draußen
sind die ganzen sports und
bushaltestellen screenshot gemacht von
den messehallen ohne chemie das riesige
halle das herausgehen
da draußen ist das pvp spiele ich immer
ohne schäden weil keine ahnung der
ruckelt es ruckelt nicht erweitern sagt
ja und hier den häuser müssten noch ein
paar sachen sein
mein gott das ist ja schon läppisch
ausgebaut
ich kann nicht warten bis alles gebaut
crossing der vergeht einfach nicht mit
ausnahmen gibt den steinstufen hier noch
zurückhalten stein steht ihnen jetzt ist
es nicht das ist natürlich jetzt total
blöd ist nicht tot
ich bin passt die sprints und
ausprobiert die töten wirklich alle
gegen 1 nr
die kosten sechs punkte nein das war so
episch wieder das war ein richtig
ethischer um drehschuss dingsbums hast
du getroffen habe ich diese hunde leicht
wirklich nicht so gut zusammen im team
oder bin ich bin gegen sind wir der sony
den schlag ich nicht diesen zusammen im
team war dann allerdings doch nicht so
ich hab's zweite stein schwer für dich
oder hasst 14 abgrenzen du wirst du am
berg
an diesem walzen ja ja ich könnte heute
runter geht da kommt einheit kommt ihr
eine entgegen wieso bleibt bestehen
irgendwas ist gerade alles bleibt
deshalb ein bisschen lag der sommer legt
ich laufe einfach mal allen vorbei dann
höre ich direkt vor die höhe
ok ich bitte wirklich um verzeihung
label ohne akzeptabel
hallo
na gut dann würde ich sagen war es das
wert gewonnen
ja gar nicht wissen die besten dialoge
machen oder so ja tut uns leid mein vips
eu 1.11 mein wort com bis u12 geht das
glaube ich nur 5 und s 1511 und dann
wild nm steht in der beschreibung keiner
vorbei morgens wahrscheinlich die
unkompliziert schaffen wenn die man dann
endlich mal wieder online war und sonst
gibt es irgendwas anderes oder nix oder
kleine mal gucken sonst wenn es euch
gefallen dürfte gerne einen daumen hoch
gehen oder uns in die kommentare
schreiben von youtube sechs minecraft
erhaltet ob er damit machen wollte und
dann dann heute danke nochmal an
christoph dass er mit dabei war griff
der ovag denke dass ich dabei sein
durfte